cinq ans après sa palme d'or pour la vie
d'adèle le nouveau film d'abdellatif
kechiche est enfin sur les écrans et
c'est notre événement de la semaine
mektoub my love kanto uno c'est ce titre
qui mêle l'arabe mektoub des stores
l'anglais miles oeuvre mon amour et
l'italien ou l'espagnol kanto où nos
champs un peut-être une référence à la
divine comédie très librement inspiré du
roman de françois bégaudeau la blessure
la vraie il raconte les amours estivales
d'une bande d'amis sous le regard du
jeune amine apprentis scénariste revenus
de paris pour les vacances le casting
mélange des débutants comme les
révélations shaibu médine et ophélie
beau dans les rôles principaux et des
comédiens déjà vu chez kechiche comme un
chien herzi qui sera notre invité tout à
l'heure et salim kechiouche et ça se
passe à 7 comme la graine et le mulet
chip
oui et c'est ça qui est formidable c'est
que quelle chiche s'est débarrassé au
maximum du côté contraintes
scénaristique pour pouvoir vraiment
embrasser ce groupe ce jeune vivre avec
eux et on sait que tout le seimat
kechiche c'est une question de regard
comment on pose son regard et ses
problématiser intérieure de l'histoire
avec le personnage d'amy qui est vous
l'avez dit apprentis scénariste mais
aussi apprentis photographes et comment
on photographie comment on capte sa et
le film c'est ça c'est comment on va
capter cette onde de désir qui circulent
au milieu de ces corps dans le soleil
dans la lumière
vous l'avez dit c'est cette c'est la
méditerranée il ya un soleil très
particulier et on sait qu'il n'a pas
hésité à changer parfois de lieu de
tournage pour avoir une meilleure
lumière ça c'est du cinéma
il ya aussi un lien avec un précédent
film de kechiche l'esquivé ce
marivaudage balnéaire ce canton où nos
où les mouches chante avec les corps
clair c'est vrai que c'est un film qui
se déroule essentiellement sur la plage
mais aussi dans cette atmosphère on va
dire communauté entre la famille le
groupe d'amis on
arrive même jusqu'à une ferme pour
suivre toute l'évolution et je trouve
que dans le parallèle c'est plutôt dans
la vie d'adèle quand on suivait à des
l'ex-sergent poulos en tant
qu'enseignante keshi disait qu'il avait
grand plaisir à filmer le milieu
scolaire là il prend grand plaisir à
filmer aussi le milieu de la ferme est
donc cette jeune fille qui est je suis
d'une famille qui élève donc des chèvres
et on va on va suivre aussi tout cet
environnement là mais en tout cas un
traitement
ouais je vous montre pas la ferme je
vous montre plutôt la plage voilà parce
que donc les acteurs sont
essentiellement maillot de bain dans ce
film on sait que ça se passe l'été il
fait chaud et il y a des dualités des
confrontations donc on a à mine sur la
gauche qui est donc cet apprenti
scénariste bière à la main qui s'éclate
en tout cas qu'ils discutaient avec son
ami qui à gauche etc etc en valeur
ophélie bo qui fait fait elle même face
à une au personnage de céline qui est
donc venu en vacances et qui est de
passage par ici on pose plutôt de les
écouter puisque la dualité est
apparemment par les parents sont
toutefois pas l'autorisation de mon
enfance en danger par rémy jarris
rivalité déjà lu ce que je vais faire
mais on sait pas trop tu vois il n'y a
pas de réponse
vu les amusantes on a tout compris et le
jeu tout le jeu il est là en fait c'est
justement quand on fait un lien avec les
skiffs c'est le personnage damine c'est
celui qui ne dévoile jamais ses
sentiments qui est vraiment un
observateur qui est un peu l'amoureux
transi qui arrive pas à déclamer sa
flamme et qui ne fait qu'écouter les
amours de son entourage sans pouvoir
vraiment y prendre part et on est aussi
dans ce marivaudage et c'est cette
enfance en fait tout le monde tous
jouent pas touche pipi mais en tout cas
voilà sa cavale sur la plage ça joue
sajou dans l'eau ça se tire les films de
groupes film de communauté et philippe
ou abdellatif kechiche utilise plusieurs
caméras en même temps souvent dans un
montage absolument virtuose basa qui est
formidable parce qu'il s'agit de
toujours suivre les intrigues des uns et
des autres et en même temps être dans le
groupe
alors moi je vous a apporté un extrait
kepa la plage mais qu'est dans l'autre
lieu où ils vont tout le temps qui est
au resto au resto et boîtes de nuit et
là on retrouve 2e place aux photos ni et
charlotte est en fait charlot d'être
amoureuse de tonic qui a peur en train
de la laisser tomber
et donc là elle a envie de lui faire
rendre des comptes mais lui il est
plutôt à vouloir se dégager à faire le
beau et donc regarder comment ils
trouvent toujours bon il devait
remplacer un peu un copain il cherche
une cigarette tout est bon pour faire un
peu faire diversion et voyez là il a
fait durer le plan kechiche et tout d'un
coup au moment d'avoir du feu bratok
il s'agit de deux de passer à un autre à
une autre caméra et tout le tout le
reste de la scène va être comme ça avec
à chaque fois regarder comment la petite
charlotte est mise à l'écart un
sélectionne charbagh qui joue ce rôle
elle est mise à l'écart du plan elle est
à la périphérie
et quand elle a appelant tout seul c'est
pour montrer son désespoir parce que
tout d'un coup elle est tout seul face
au groupe tout le monde le groupe fait
face et elle l ai regardé la haye
disparaît du cadre elle elle essaye de
subsister mais elle est dans une autre
conversation elle elle veut avoir une
conversation privée avec celui qu'ils
considèrent toujours comme sur thébaux
dedans on se voit on se voit pas
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui se passe
alors que lui ne pense qu'à s'amuser
il veut qu'on met de la musique et la
caméra bas le jeu du montage doit capter
ça et donc on mélange les prises on
mélange les les angles de caméra il ya
certes parfois quinze caméras et là tout
d'un coup il s'agit de capter à vierzy
qui avec amine et qui commentent la
scène qu'on vient de voir donc
il s'agit à chaque fois d'être dans la
meilleure position de profiter du groupe
tout en pouvant être ému par les destins
individuels c'est ça la vraie difficulté
du jeu en europe tout en sachant que il
laisse ses interprètes improvisé des
choses par exemple cette idée géniale du
photographe
il semblerait que c'est shy'm noureddine
qu'il a apporté en disant et si j'étais
photographe
ce qui est intéressant c'est le fils
nicolas est librement adapté on l'a dit
d'un roman de françois bégaudeau la
blessure la vraie et on a l'impression
peut-être ces faux d'ailleurs qu'à des
risques et six églises quelque chose de
lui
alors je n'ai pas lu de bégaudeau donc
je serai je serais bien en peine de
faire la comparaison ce qui est certain
ce qui est évident c'est que à travers
ce personnage damine qui est scénariste
et photographe il est évident vu que ya
un parallèle avec la position de
réalisateur il ya quelque chose
d'intéressant d'ailleurs dans le regard
de kechiche parce que on va le voir une
va certainement en reparler la caméra
est complètement vampirisé par tous ces
corps féminin qui déborde littéralement
leurs vêtements de leurs maillots de
bain leur short la caméra les suit la
caméra même des sens nous montrent leurs
fesses leurs seins tout le temps certes
la caméra est vampirisée par ses
personnages féminins et par le désir
qu'elle suscite à l'homme derrière la
caméra mais l'homme devant la caméra
hammink et se double de kechiche et bien
pourtant tout tout tout tout c'est lui
le désir personnes c'est à dire que lui
et le centre du désir alors que la
caméra ne désire que les femmes qu'il
filme donc une espèce de jeu de regards
entre la caméra de kechiche son
personnage principal et ce groupe de
femmes et où parfois il ya des moments
où on arrive tout de même il peut être
qu'on peut en parler à une forme quand
même d'insistance de malaise de cette
caméra qui colle aux fesses un point tel
que iliad bien il ya des moments où ils
nous étouffent un peu dans le désir dans
le désir de réalisateurs qui nous soumet
à l'image pendant trois heures simon
l'alleud c'est très intéressant
d'ailleurs ces deux extraits que vous
avez choisi parce que ce sont à mon sens
vraiment les refrains dans le champ qui
est ce film le souci c'est qu'entre sert
fin on a découplé et moi je le trouve
que ces couples et ils sont un peu longs
et qu'on tombe parfois quand même dans
le max pecas sous lexomil
de l'agnelage parce que c'est
extraordinaire quand mais non mais
justement c'est la quintessence du
cinéma de kechiche cayla c'est à dire
que lui il veut photographier la
naissance d'un petit agneau et et l'idée
c'est que à quelle position semé parce
que si on est trop près la brebis elle
va pas porter bas elle va vous empêcher
littéralement de voir et c'est la même
chose avec les comédiens c'est à dire
qu'il faut trouver le bon angle la bonne
distance et cette séquence là mais c'est
totalement c'est totalement bouleversant
c'est une épiphanie du cinéma oui et en
même temps elle et elle et elle est
insoutenable au bout d'un moment mais
moi c'est ce qui me passionne dans le
film d'ailleurs à cesser cette bagarre
que j'ai constamment avec kechiche dans
ses films il ya des gens pour qui ça va
être très pénible
il faut il faut le savoir c'est à dire
que ce conte ce qu'on a fait là dans les
extraits qui était très beau par exemple
c'est quelqu'un qui sait n'a été aussi
un contre-jour c'est à dire qu'on a le
soleil dans les yeux dans ce film là
avec cette caméra portée tremblay ce
truc et les vingt premières minutes on
se demande vraiment si on va tenir
parfois filmées sous le signe de la
lainière d'accor asie les bourses
avaient crû de 17 agents mais parle de
lumière c'est le sujet et comme souvent
avec kechiche en fait on rend les armes
et sert que en fait ce que je trouve
très beau c'est que ce qui donne à voir
il le donne à vivre et que tout à coup
cette sensation de l'été
ce goût de la jeunesse le halle aux
grains dépôts etc
cette fascination pour les fesses
d'ophélie qui sont les lésés granville
derby sous les 0 riche en films à paris
mais c'est elle qui mène ce petit monde
et c'était excellent effet ce qui mène
le monde enfin il vraiment une
révélation comme un dingue mais m'arrive
quelque chose de très important une fois
il faut dire que le film dure trois
heures et qu' il faut reconnaître il
faut abdiquer face au talent que les
adrs kechiche parce que quand on
commence on se retrouve quoi on se
retrouve face à ce qui fait d'habitude
serre qui pose ses caméras et on se
retrouve face à des acteurs qui parle
t'on pas qu'on en dise il attend bien là
les chinois pour ça comment ça commence
par la scène vécue
donc il nous met dedans et vous avez un
mac os x pourrait dire que c'est
vraiment gonflé la droite pour appâter
spectateurs mais peu importe pourquoi
pas on commence par une scène de cul
effectivement hyper brut et ensuite on
tombe dans le cinéma de kechiche c'est à
dire des gens qui sont en chant contre
chant qui parle sans dialogues qu'un
provisions pas grand chose à se dire
début c'est vrai qu'on se dit alors ils
m'ont merde kechiche
il ment merde a essayé de m'attraper
comme ça par une scène de cul un petit à
sierre qui m'emmerde à mettre ces
acteurs amateurs qui ont pas grand chose
à dire et qui joue un peu à côté de la
plaque
et puis au bout d'un moment comme le dit
marie on abdique parce que le film est
tellement plus que ça guy abdication
clair mais c'est sa méthode moi je
dirais c'est pas c'est pas mon film
préféré du coup de kechiche pourtant je
sais que c'est son univers en fait c'est
d'un coup j'ai vu ces stratagèmes voilà
on met les acteurs ensemble on laisse
tourner la caméra et on va tirer là
l'essence en fait des interactions entre
c'est un film qui sera la bonne époque
puisque c'est un film estival et nous on
a froid donc on est content d'aller en
salle et de la bernina mère juste pour
reprendre lé cédric et qui renvoie
complètement à l'adolescence et ce
moment des vacances pourquoi quand on
est en vacances il ya ce truc cette
interaction ce désir cette envie de
séduire de total etc
je trouve ça très infime qui est qui est
très forte de ce côté là et pour
reprendre dans la méthode kechiche avait
une anecdote que m'avait dit salim
kechiouche qui datent de la villa del et
qui était sur le l'intention en fait
kechiche tu as fait apprendre par coeur
une déclaration d'amour qu'il devait
faire à des l'extérieur poulos dans le
film est donc salim apprend apprend à
prendre et quand il arrive sur le
plateau il s'élance pour déclamer son
texte
hélas kechiche crie coupez donc s'allume
quelque chose avait les jambes coupées
l'heure mais j'ai passé mon temps à
prendre ce texte dit non je voulais
l'intention j'ai capté l'instant sur la
lave et a déclamé en mylar les affres du
cinéma pur mais c'est ça en fait moi
c'est ça qui me passionne c'est à dire
que j'ai on entend beaucoup de
références et moi c'est marrant celle
qui m'est venue fait malik est pas du
tout parce que sur le film ressemble à
la ville au cms de c'est du pur cinéma
c'est une histoire qui peut pas être
racontée autrement qu'en cinéma ça
pourrait pas être un scénario qu'on lit
ça pourrait pas être une pièce de
théâtre c'est du cinéma pur et séduit
kechiche au carré j'ai envie de dire la
quintessence de son ca à cesson plus
radicale ça m'a passionné
mektoub my love d'abdellatif kechiche
cours et découvrir le kanto où noé
cinéma en attendant à la suite peut-être
à cannes qui s'est dès le mois de mai